we can speak now to poland's deputy
foreign minister marcin pritch thank you
very much for being with us and first of
all
uh on this cutting off of gas supplies
how damaging
could that be for your country
well first of all of course
to say that it was a unfriendly step
taken by russia is to say nothing
it seems that russia is not a reliable
partner but we know that we knew that in
poland that one day russia may try to
blackmail us with the
cutting of the
energy supplies that's why we've decided
to diversify
our
energy or gas supplies
the conservative government of poland
decided many years ago to build a lng
terminal so we do have
lng supplies from the u.s and gulf
countries but we do have also
many interconnectors built recently in
recent years so we can get to gas also
from our
neighbors and finally what we've done uh
recently again
is to build a
baltic
pipeline a kind of
connection with with norway so that we
can also import norwegian gas our
storages are in ninety percent full yeah
so we will manage with that don't worry
about it it shows only that russia can
play again
energy as an instrument to get to to get
their political goals
well that's interesting and given all
those other sources that you are
mentioning how close do you think you
are to being able to
rely um
on your own other sources and and not
have to deal with russia at all are you
close to that
we've been we've been already planning
uh since the uh the current contract
with gastro will be terminated
should be
in the end of this year so um that was
uh the the last day of possible
energy supplies from russia so what we
really need to do is to um manage to do
to do you know somehow fulfill our our
internal domestic obligations until the
end of this new year but what it's more
and we've been already planning to
phase out
of russian fossil fuels
this year we don't want to be a part of
this business anymore since
we've been already warning our partners
that russia has been using the money
getting or collected from the
european member states
to finance their war in ukraine so this
is a very bad business for all of us and
we've been advocating a complete ban
on fossil fuels from from russia i hope
that our german and other partners dutch
partners will follow our example uh and
and cut off all all of those energy
links with russia
well that's a very good question i mean
do you think they will because germany
of course
relies very heavily on russia for its
gas supplies
yes that was their political decision
we've been telling them constantly
that's why i mean maybe uh relations
between poland and
germany has had its ups and downs we've
been very critical about north stream 2
pipeline and no stream one pipeline uh
pipeline all those uh gas connections
between germany and and russia mostly
because of the fact that being dependent
on russian gas
means that they were also dependent on
russian political will we've been trying
to convince them to diversify just like
the european institutions we're
advocating we've done it the homework in
poland
hopefully germany will will do the same
if not it seems that the european union
is too
much dependent on russia we need to
finish that we are ready to express our
solidarity to help our
german neighbors if that is needed but
first they need to take this political
decision to be less dependent on russia
and to be fully
in line with the european interest
yeah and just finally and a minute or so
left uh the foreign secretary british
foreign secretary uh is reported to be
about to say tonight that um she thinks
that the west should double down now on
weapons to ukraine and
give more tanks and more heavy weapons
and
more aircraft
do you
go along with that do you support what
she's saying
oh absolutely we are one of the most
active uh
countries
um with regard to the
not only humanitarian or financial
support to ukraine but in terms of
military equipment we've already gave
our ukrainian neighbors
military equipment worth 1.7 billion of
dollars so that's a lot uh also the
heavy equipment
it was neither said i don't want to go
into detail but
also tanks where many tanks were sent to
the ukraine in order to help them not
only to survive but to win this war and
i hope that uh
having this example the example of
americans and brit
also other european member states will
be more actively supporting ukraine
because ukraine is at war
with with russia unjustified unfair were
unprovoked and it is russia the bedside
an aggressive actor in this war we need
to support our european ukrainian
neighbor
okay marcin pradacha thank you very much
indeed for your time